one of the biggest box-office hits since
the Nickelodeon the Star Wars I saw and
like you I was enchanted by the
performance of its hero may the force
always be with him here is Mark Hamill
may the force be with you the far
speaking with me or not did I say that I
don't believe that I said that did I say
the first really well I know the force
is always been
this is not the kind of close encounter
I had
we're here to present hey yourself how
to mark is talking of course I'm just as
excited as you are now do be quiet you
see my friends here are a perfect
example of the combined talents of actor
and technician creating creatures that
never existed and sounds that have never
been heard before you know I sometimes
feel like Zeppo Marx alongside Groucho
and Zeff Harpo unique sounds at a
distinct dimension too and we were here
tonight to honor two very special
achievements excuse me mark he's excited
about a special film Close Encounters Oh
the Third Kind it was really nice to
have Anthony Daniels as c-3po to say all
the hard parts the Board of Governors of
the Academy upon recommendation of a
select committee of the sound ranch has
given a special sound effects editing
award to Close Encounters of the Third
Kind the award goes to mr. Frank
follow my own act for this honor I thank
the Board of Governors and the special
sound committee to julia and michael
phillips and steve spielberg three very
special people thank you very much for
the freedom to express myself and to my
dear friends who share this with me
thank you
uhaah she's a little nervous we don't
have to thank anyone the Academy's
already done that and now for the other
movie which I think these two are
particularly interested in a special
achievement award has been voted by the
Board of Governors upon the
recommendation of the sound ranch
executive committee for the creation of
the alien creature and robot voices
featured in Star Wars the award goes mr.
Benjamin Burt jr.
I'd like to specifically thank Ken Miura
of USC cinema and producer Gary curries
for giving me a start on his film and
for associate producer Jim Nelson whose
great friendship and encouraged me and
encouragement helped me out father uh
was helped me a lot during the film I
like the of course thank George Lucas
who had all the great ideas and provided
all the inspiration for the things in
Star Wars thank you very much